[Music]
on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
our players will not censor tonight
world-class sportsman turned world
leader imran khan's gripping interview
on putin boris johnson and surviving
assassination plots my exclusivity with
usain bolt the fastest man in history
and as the seminal pop masterpiece
american pie turns 50 music maestro don
mclean opens up the timeless hit that
became a national anthem but now an
interview with a giant of world sport
even bigger giant of world politics
imran khan was one of the finest
cricketers on the planet over 10 years
as captain of pakistan he became the
nation's hero and then later
sensationally it's prime minister but he
was deposed after losing an acrimonious
confidence vote uh in april so i began
by asking for his verdict on the british
prime minister who of course has just
about survived his
i keep telling our people in pakistan
that this would not even have made news
here
you know the in in in time of government
uh prime minister having a a drinks
get together after work would not even
have made news here because we also
unlike the rest of the world we also had
to cope with government 19 and all the
restrictions
so
you know
here people can't understand what's
going on but i understand and i in one
way
this is one thing which i
feel that the reason why british
parliamentary system works
whereas
apart from
non
anglo-saxon countries it doesn't work
because of the very high
level of moral standards you expect from
your leadership
so
unfortunately it doesn't work in other
countries where they do not have the
level of moral standards that you you
expect from your parliamentarians right
i mean i think the issue here really is
not about partying it's about the
hypocrisy and double standard of a prime
minister who himself was fined by the
police for breaking his own lockdown
rules and over 80 of his own downing
street staff were also fined by the
police and it's the brazen double
standard of a group of people that were
ordering the british public
not to go even go and see dying
relatives dying from covert in hospital
they couldn't do that and at the same
time the people making those very
draconian rules
were brazenly breaking them themselves i
think that's the issue
what stood out in britain was that high
level i repeat of
moral standards you expect from your
leadership
in pakistan you know the vote of no
confidence against me which took place
the whole country knew that the going
rate to buy my parliamentarians was a
million dollars
so i mean if you compare the two
uh that's why you know in my opinion and
i keep telling them of my experience in
british
of parliament that unless we raise our
level of morality to what you have in
britain
parliamentary democracy will not work if
you if all it takes is to buy 20 of your
members of parliament to switch sides
and a government falls
it
in fact the whole concept of democracy
or parliamentary democracy then gets
challenged so you know from br from your
point of view in britain of what i know
i understand that you expect from your
leadership the standards you expect them
to delete by example
it's been very volatile since you were
deposed uh you vowed to come back and
fight again you think you're gonna win
with a bigger majority i believe
but one issue that's come up in the last
few days there appears to be a serious
threat
of assassination
against you and i have to say the last
leader of pakistan i spoke to was
benazir bhutto and it wasn't long after
i met her that she was indeed
assassinated so this is a very serious
risk that you all face i think when you
lead a country like pakistan
what do you know about these threats how
seriously are you taking them
well
because what happened was that this was
clearly a conspiracy and
you know i've spoken about the
conspiracy because you know i came to
know about it about six months before i
actually
uh before this vote of no confidence
took place
and uh
you know all the time i thought it
wouldn't succeed you know for some
reason i thought that
uh
it's not possible that you know the
conspiracy was to replace me
by the guys who for 30 years had been in
power the two families
and there were massive corruption cases
against them
60 percent of the cabinet that has
replaced me is on bail
or billions of rupees of corruption
cases so my mind just wouldn't accept
that
would it be possible to replace our
government which was which had finally
recovered from all the two years of
crises and was on on the way up
i just didn't think it would be replaced
by these criminals
so
those who sort of planned this whole
thing
uh a bit worried now because they don't
want me back they didn't
take me out to get me back in again
so that's when i got
i found out that they had planned this
final solution but you were known imran
as on the cricket field you were known
as completely fearless no opponent ever
put fear into you but when you're a
political leader and you're in the
situation that you're in now
uh where there's a genuine threat
against you of assassination do you feel
fear
no you know beers i that is well when i
entered politics i actually had
conquered my fear of dying otherwise i
would not have entered politics because
i came in to stand up against the entire
status quo i came
came to fight corruption
today the entire political
spectrum
16 parties on one side and i'm on the
other side
and because this was the status quo
which has
60 years of our last 62 years half has
been ruled by military and half by these
two families so i came to fight these
two families and this is really what i
i've done and they
have made so much money out of this that
they obviously
clearly someone like me is a threat and
and that's why this uh
foreign-backed conspiracy
involving local players took place now
i know that they would uh try to my life
has had various threats over a period of
time but this time
i found out about this conspiracy so i
went public the reason i have no fear of
dying but it is it was important to let
those guys were planning to let them
know that i know right it was actually
in a way a form of protection you went
to moscow
as it turned out on the very day that
vladimir putin the russian leader
invaded ukraine and you know how
controversial the images of you and
putin then immediately became because it
looked like you were almost endorsing
what he was doing because you stayed in
moscow and completed your trip
do you regret now not just leaving
immediately you heard that he'd invaded
ukraine i promise you i had no idea i
arrived the night before i was only
there for one night next morning when i
wake up i discovered that this uh
ukraine adventure had started
now it was uh
we discussed amongst ourselves
we realized that there was very poor
timing but at the same time we realized
that we really it was extremely
important for the 220 million people of
pakistan that we actually uh get these i
mean i understand that i understand i
completely understand that you didn't
know before you made the trip i guess
the criticism which may be legitimate is
that once you knew what he'd done
to then stay
there
and still go through with the meetings
that you had planned
sent the world a message that you
were not that upset by what he was doing
in ukraine countries like us
you know who have huge populations and
we have 100 million people who are
vulnerable right now so we should
actually
make policies have be have relationship
with everyone but make policies that
benefit our people i understand that
india is doing i
the higher understand standards in the
uk when it comes to holding leaders to
account
i simply would say i don't criticize you
for having planned a trip to moscow but
i think there is legitimate criticism
that once you knew what he had done it
illegally invaded a sovereign democratic
country
did your moral instinct not tell you
that it would be wrong to stay there
that you should have just got straight
out of there
because i am against all military
operations i am i i
march with the with those two million
people in in london against iraq war i
constantly was against the afghanistan
war that there was no military solution
i do not believe what putin has done of
trying to find a military solution in
ukraine i always believe these are
miscalculations they cause a lot of
hardship and i did give a statement in
when i was in moscow that military is
not the military actions are not a
solution unfortunately we were left at
it at the the time was
either we then
and by the way the meeting was
more or less an are before
when we discovered that the the
they had invaded ukraine it was a
question a one hour in between to decide
whether we abandoned the trip or
or or or have the meeting with putin and
so eventually we decided that look at
this stage we will fall between two
stools with russia we will break all
relationship leaving at this juncture
and at the at the same time you know is
it going to make any difference if we if
pakistan decides to sort of uh show
condem russian invasion by leaving there
are you in a position now to see what
putin has done
in ukraine
and emphatically publicly denounce it
any conflict and especially with where
you go and
any conflict creates bloodshed
but
you know just like uh
in iraq in afghanistan god knows how
many people died there and similarly in
ukraine
going into uh ukraine the sort of
what we are saying right now i am i i'm
sure that uh if uh
president putin realized what was
happening right now he wouldn't have uh
uh started this but do you personally
condemn
the war in ukraine now knowing what
you've seen in the last three months
let me just say one thing i
you know i am basically anti against all
uh operations
so if you if you want to uh ask me a
question
uh do i condemn what is happening in
what happened in iraq i thought it was
wrong and i would condemn that i have
afghanistan u.s going in and then sting
okay once they
once they got decimated al-qaeda in the
first year what was the purpose of
staying there for the next 19 years so
it was a useless war and yes if you know
if i would advising president putin i
would not have gone there and yes a war
that creates bloodshed
and which is which it is and collateral
damage and civilians yes
let me ask you about afghanistan because
from the moment the americans led the
rather dramatic and chaotic and many
think disastrous
overnight pull out from afghanistan and
its forces
it it seems the taliban have basically
wrestled back control of the country at
record speed and are now going back to
running the country how the taliban did
before notably with severe oppression of
women in afghanistan what is your view
of that because you've been broadly
supportive i think of the taliban being
able to run the country again but are
you supportive of the way they treat
women there
let the people of afghanistan decide
which way they will go they're strong
people i found women are strong in my
opinion given a chance you will see them
asserting their rights but the last
thing we should do is
try to interfere in people of uh the
with the afghan government they're very
proud people
i know from experience that at any hint
of outside interference in their uh
any country interfering in their way of
life they will
they're very uh
defensive about it i want to take you
back to the the late 70s the early 80s
to
the genteel world of cricket uh where
you were a champion cricketer you were a
handsome playboy on the british social
scene with a number of girlfriends to
make all of us jealous
life was a lot easier for you then a lot
more fun a lot more carefree
you become a very
powerful
very divisive in some ways uh political
figure now in pakistan do you ever have
any regrets do you ever wish you hadn't
gone down the political path for me you
know life is not about
i feel that uh you know people who find
the easy way of life
easy way of life for me a purposeless
existence means nothing to me i have you
know i have everything i've ever wanted
in life so for me the challenge is
to actually go back make pakistan a
welfare state and
rule of law critical thing is
what you are seeing in britain is
basically rule of law which is one thing
i learned most of all when i went to
england as an 18 year old imam khan it's
great to talk to you again it's been uh
well nearly 50 years since i last talked
to you
uh last time i was steaming at you in
the next hove county cricket ground so
it's it's great to catch up with you
again and i wish you all the very best
thank you very much my pleasure
on says the next he's the fastest man in
the world ever and an eight-time olympic
gold medalist blink but don't miss it
usain bolt is off the break
[Music]
so
well if one man knows all about
sacrifice mental resilience and winning
is probably the fastest man in the
history of the world and in my opinion
the greatest athlete of all time usain
bolt won eight olympic gold medals he
holds a world record in the hundred and
two hundred meter sprints is blistering
9.58 second finish in 2009 remains
unassailed and his biggest achievement
of all i'm sure he would agree in his
most punishing assignment was that he
won soccer aid as captain in 2019 with
me as his manager and i inspired him to
score were you saying bolt returns to
the london stadium this sunday to lead
the world 11 at soccer it again for
unicef and i'm delighted to say you're
saying joins me now well skipper i i
still see you as my skipper how are you
i'm good i'm good pierce i'm good now
obviously you you don't have your
world-class coach with you this time so
how confident are you that you can win
without me
well i was planning to give you a call
get some tips just to make sure keep the
energy eye you know i mean ask you what
to tell the guys so
i just need that energy and i'm sure
we'll do well do you know what struck me
you say when i when i had the pleasure
of spending a few days with you on
soccer i don't think i've ever seen
anyone who tried harder than you
to be brilliant at another sport
obviously you're the greatest athlete
has ever lived but your dedication to
football
is extraordinary you really do love the
game don't you
yeah definitely is a it's a sports that
i really loved um coming up um as a
youngster and i watch as you know i'm a
manchester united supporter so
i definitely keep abreast of what's
going on in the world when it comes to
football so when i play i don't want to
play at my best
a good friend of mine is cristiano
ronaldo uh obviously at manchester
united again at the moment and you're
very similar characters in the sense
that i think at the core of your
incredible success the pair of you is a
an almost unbelievable mental strength
and resilience that goes with your
talent
i mean do you think that without that
you would have achieved anything like
the success you've had
no i definitely think you have to be
resilient and and never give up you know
i mean you have to always want to do
more um
you have to never be satisfied and i
think that i agree with you i'm like
christine is like that he never gives up
no matter how much goals he scores he
wants to score more i was watching him
the other day and he scored two goal and
he missed one and he was so upset with
himself you know i mean he he just
always wants to do more and do better
and and that's the kind of mindset that
gets you to the top
and keeps you there yeah i completely
agree and i think itself it's a
self-fulfilling thing it's got to come
from within hasn't it because no one can
teach that to people i don't think
right i fully agree with this you can't
teach that you have to learn that from a
young age and
and just through growing up and wanting
something you know i mean you can't you
can't teach us because we have tried to
explain to young guys coming up which
you see at the talent and they don't
really understand you know i mean so for
me i think you have to have that mindset
and that drive to to want to be the best
and just want to be dominant
could you ever celebrate coming second
do you say anything
no i feel like
no definitely not no
that's all you have to do i'm a sore
yeah sorry yeah exactly yeah i want to
talk to you just about a few things that
are bubbling around the news which i was
really curious what your perspective
would be on it
the first one is the english football
manager gareth southgate came out a
couple of days ago and he was talking
about the euros final last year where a
young black player bakayosaka actually
plays for my team arsenal missed a
penalty and so did several other black
players they got abused uh racially
abused because of it by complete morons
and southgate actually said the other
day that you know it would make him
think again in future about whether he
would let young black players take
penalties in that kind of situation
which i thought was an incredibly
dispiriting thing for him to have to
admit to what do you make what do you
make of that
that's that's tough to hear you know i
mean i've never i didn't hear this
comment but that's tough you know i mean
um
a lot of these guys they don't
understand the pressure
you know i mean standing in front of um
so many people in the weight of england
on your shoulder taking a penalty is no
joke and for somebody to say they
wouldn't give that person a chance
again to to prove themselves because
especially osaka is very young
he's new to it you know i mean it's hard
on the younger ones it's it's a learning
process you know i mean and he will get
better over the years so that's
that's tough to hear somebody said about
a black player
i think he did it from a kind of
protective viewpoint he didn't want to
expose them
to abuse but i don't think you can take
that view can you
no i think you have to give our body a
chance you know i mean you have to give
that person a chance to
to be
himself you know i mean you learn from
your mistakes
and i'm sure you will learn from the
pressure and the more he plays football
the better you get so
i feel like everybody deserves a chance
you know i mean you should always give
the person the best player the chance to
go and prove himself and what advice you
say would you give to a young black
athlete sportsman whatever who's getting
racially abused on social media whatever
it may be
you must have had this i guess over the
years because twitter and so on is full
of complete idiots but yeah what would
your advice be to how to handle that
for me i stayed away from all
social media all media outlets i never
read the news pretty much so my
when i started out young
i i went through that a lot and i
figured out if if i don't read the
comments if i don't read the newspaper
if i don't watch the news then i won't
hear you know i mean my friends who are
close around me um
they understand that they don't tell me
negative things
you know i mean so i just stayed away
from it you know i mean if you don't
read it if you don't listen to it you
won't hear so that's i think that's very
good advice the less you read the better
right and the purer your head can be
without this stuff in your head yeah i
want to turn to the um
this whole issue of sport washing you've
got it with the golf uh stars at the
moment who've decided to play in a saudi
arabian funded new tournament and it's
causing a huge furore but at the center
of it really is this question of whether
sports stars
should
have to be careful about countries they
align themselves with for sport i know
that you've i don't think you've ever
run competitively in saudi but you've
certainly done some work there speeches
and so on
i mean what's your view about this
where's is there a line that you
wouldn't cross
for me i think everybody is different
views are different in these in these
times now everything is different it's
hard to to say what's going to offend
people you know i mean and it's
it's really tricky right now i have a
team that
kind of tried to protect me or try to
make sure we're on a straight line and
to make sure we don't offend anybody as
much as we possibly can but it's it's
tricky right now with what's going on in
the world with
everything you know you have to be very
careful with what you say and what you
do nowadays so it's just all about
understanding a situation
i mean i look at it and think there's a
lot of hypocrisy
amongst the criticism because if you
have the olympics in somewhere like
china
and then i don't see an issue
particularly with golfers playing in a
saudi-sponsored golf tournament because
to me you either take a completely black
and white view of human right records of
countries or you don't
yeah as i said it's it's all about
people look at things you know i mean
everybody has a different view
on everything this is why i stay away
from these things you know i mean i
again i have my team
i care for what i i say i just
try to stay focused on me and try to do
what i need to do to to stay
positive
what do you think of this issue you're
saying about trans athletes which is
obviously getting a lot of attention
at the moment a lot of people feel
it's unfair for trans athletes to
compete against women born to female
biological bodies you know we could have
a situation where if you wanted to
and you felt this way you could identify
as a woman and compete against women
would do you think that would be fair
reasonable
for me
i always say i'm not the person who
makes the rules you know i mean um even
when i was running and it was
the that i was asking about
drugs and who should be banned i always
say rules are the rules
i think a lot of rules will be changed
in the future and it will be adjusted so
for me i just go along with the rules as
they are now
but do you think when you see what's
going on in swimming for example michael
phelps came out and said he didn't think
it was
fair would it be fair for for
sprinters who who've been born males to
then transition and compete against
women
well that's not for me to answer you
know i mean i think as again it's a
tricky situation
you know i mean it's
it's for a discussion and it's not for
me to say you know i mean it's it's up
in here i would say but in time as i
said in times things will change
um so just give it time and see where it
goes but just to clarify you're not
thinking of identifying as a woman
anytime soon
[Laughter]
after the break with no end in sight to
the bloody war in ukraine is the only
solution to take out the narcissistic
bully at the kremlin former cia director
leon panetta who oversaw the operation
to bring down osama bin laden is
uncensored next
[Music]
so
this is talk tv
[Music]
well we're not more than 100 days into
the war in ukraine and the brutal
conflicts in danger of entering a
torturous and protracted stalemate the
uk is now warning the conflict could
last as long as a decade so a pause for
thought take a look at these five
pictures and ask yourself what links
them afghanistan yemen libya iraq syria
all devastating wars which cost
thousands of lives sparked humanitarian
disasters and all too briefly commanded
the entire planet's attention
and then we moved on
so is ukraine now in danger it'd be the
next that we simply move on from
well picking up on that now i'm joined
by the man who as director of the cia
oversaw the killing of osama bin laden
the former u.s defense secretary leon
panetta mr thank you so much for joining
peace morgan censored
good to be with you pierce
just discussing there with the
ambassador uh here in london about the
situation
in ukraine
putin is slowly but surely barreling his
way through that country what more
should the world be doing to try and
stop him
well we're a hundred days into this war
uh we really have been through
what i call three stages of the war the
first was
a failed invasion by russia
uh the world uh stood up uh ukrainians
stood up and were able to essentially
stop the russians from achieving their
goal of getting the capital and bringing
ukraine down
the second stage is siege warfare and
tremendous destruction and killing of
innocent men women and children to try
to break the will of the ukrainian
people that failed as well
and the third stage is the one we're in
now which is this war of attrition
uh with russia trying to gain
uh territory in the east
in order to have leverage i assume for
negotiations
how long that war of attrition goes on
no one really knows it could continue
for weeks and months
it could result in negotiation which is
what the world obviously hopes for
or it could escalate uh into something
worse
the decision as to what happens
really rests with putin
and nobody else right now
henry kissinger suggested that ukraine
may have to see territory to end the war
the ukrainians obviously don't want to
do that
but is that something which perhaps
becomes inevitable the longer this goes
on
i think president biden was right in
saying that that decision has to rest
with ukraine uh and with zielinski uh
they're the ones that are fighting and
dying putting their lives on the line
every day in order to defend their
country
i think it's up to them to decide uh
what the basis of any possible
negotiation should be i don't think
anybody ought to tell them what they
should or should not do they're the ones
that have fought for the right to decide
what what will be on the table should
they negotiate
if you'd still be in defense secretary
or even running the cia you know every
single in my body
wants to attack vladimir putin to take
him on to kick him out of ukraine to use
the might of the nato military the most
powerful ever seen but he's been able to
so far successfully rattle his nuclear
saber as a kind of warning card to keep
people away
how long should we sustain that kind of
threat where he simply says if you do
anything
uh proactively here i will
nuke you
look i don't think we can be intimidated
by by putin
uh putin
has sensed weakness on the part of the
west for a long time that's why he went
into the crimea that's why he went into
syria and libya uh and that's why he
attacked this country with a very bold
cyber attack against our election
systems
because he sensed weakness
i think for the first time the united
states and our allies have come together
in a unified way
to say that uh putin will pay a price
for his aggression uh and by providing
uh the weapons necessary for the
ukrainians uh by
imposing the sanctions uh that uh are
really hitting the russian economy
seriously
and by re-strengthening our position in
the nato countries i think the us
and our allies
have done the right thing
in trying to stop putin
putin needs to be stopped bullies need
to be stopped
uh and the message that went to russia
is frankly the same message that needs
to go to china and north korea and iran
and other adversaries we have got to
come together as allies in order to stop
this kind of aggression
i want to pivot just uh briefly it's
over 10 years incredibly since
osama bin laden was killed in that
remarkable raid you were immortalized in
a massively successful movie zero dark
30 played by james james gandolfini who
apparently had to
write to you before it even aired
apologizing for everything he said
including including his wig so i want to
play you a clip and then come for your
reaction
i'm about to go look the president in
the eye
and what i'd like to know no
it's where everyone stands on this thing
now
very simply
is he there or is he not in there
i gotta say i thought you came out of
that brilliantly and i don't know you
but if i was you i would have loved all
that
well uh i remember when uh gandalfini
wrote me a note uh and said you know you
probably don't like the way i played
this role uh but i really admire you so
i called him up i met him at some events
uh and uh he said uh
he said you know he said i i i hope uh i
hope you like the way i played it i said
look i said it's a movie i'm glad they
picked an italian to play in italian
that that made me feel good uh and he
came back and he said you know he said
they made me use a lot of four-letter
words and i said well you know that's
the one thing you got right
it's it's actually a great film i think
the the the best thing imaginable is
when someone makes a big movie like that
is that it's good and i think not only
was it good but you have this amazing
actor playing you and as i say i thought
you came out as badass mr panetta and
that's that's really how a former boss
of a cia wants to be right
well it was uh it was a tremendous
experience and i give a lot of credit to
both the military and intelligence
people for coming together working
together because that was the most
effective way to counter terrorism
did you still get uh just finally do you
still get people
thanking you personally when they see
you for taking out bin laden
i think the most rewarding thing that
ever happens to me is uh particularly
when a family
of uh of those that were killed on 9 11
uh when members of that family see me
and thank me
for uh
for bringing justice
uh to uh to bin laden for what he did to
our country uh that's the most rewarding
feeling of law well politicians get a
lot of a a bad rap over time but that
was a stunning
a stunning moment i think for america
for that administration for you
personally and so you know
11 years on now isn't it um thank you
for what you did for the world because
you took out the worst terrorists in the
world and that's got to be a good
feeling
it was uh it was very important to send
a message to the world that nobody
attacks our country and gets away with
it uh and i was very proud of that
operation leo great to talk to you thank
you very much for being on the show
thank you well it says the next uh one
of surprisingly one of my biggest fans
i love your tv show i still remember
many interviews that you did you were a
very very good interviewer and i always
made a point of watching it and i still
know about all the trouble you cause on
morning television
well i'm a massive fan of don mclean as
well and we got him a surprise tribute
from one of his biggest fans too
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
so
possibly the most iconic lyrics in
american music history is behind them
singer don mclean join me to discuss the
legacy of that classic song which turns
50. and why he said bye-bye to the nra
in the wake of the recent texas school
shooting he began writing american pie
in his early 20s so i began the
interview by asking whether he already
knew that he had a mega hit on his hands
i felt that i was a special songwriter i
was quite egotistical
in that sense i felt i had
certain gifts and i wanted to
i never had anybody tell me what to do
on a record i would write what i wanted
or i wouldn't sign the contract
so i was in complete control and that
album american pie
i had all the songs except the one that
i wanted which was the big one
and i spent 10 years really thinking
about buddy holly before i finally
came up with that first part because i
wanted a big song about america
and when i came up with that i said you
know i'll tie that
up
with the ideas that i have for this song
and then i i knew i was really on my way
and i don't write songs like most other
people do and therefore
i'm not nearly as successful because i
don't have a formula of any sort i do
something once and then that's it
they'll never be an american pie too or
anything like that
this will be a staggeringly important
question but i'm going to ask it anyway
i've been trying to work out how much
money you must have made from american
pie given i assume it is playing
somewhere in the world at any given
moment
well it's see i'm an album artist and um
i was just on good morning america and
they presented me with a plaque
that was surprised me that i have been
certified as having sold over 50 million
albums worldwide wow people buy my
albums that's why they come to the shows
of course
everybody knows american pie but if
everybody that knows that song came to
my shows i'd be selling out stadiums
so you see they they know the song but
it's my fans who know the albums and
those songs like you know crossroads and
empty chairs and babylon and
vincent and castles in the air and i
love you so these songs are known to
millions and millions of people but the
big the big boy you know the big tree in
the forest of course is always american
pie when you when you wrote american pie
in
obviously we started with the buddy
holly a bit we all know that but it's
it's it in many ways it was an anthem
for the state of america and how you
felt about it at the time
how do you feel
america has changed in the last 50 years
well i tried to get the craziness of
america
as well as the hugeness of it
into the song the size of it it had to
be a massive song for this massive
country full of contradictions full of
love and anger and hatred and creative
genius all at once
and that was all in the back of my crazy
mind i was writing this for myself but i
must say that i think
america is getting more crazy and less
sane i wanted to talk to you about the
events of last week in america in
particular because
there was another horrendous mass
shooting at a school
and you were due to perform at the nra
conference
two days later and you picked that and
you pulled out of that
of that performance why did you pull out
and what did you think about the
shooting what what can america do
about this ongoing epidemic of gun
violence
well i pulled out because it would be a
horrendously bad taste to be there
and the only reason i did the show was
because i i kind of like western things
you know western guns western rifles
indian things i thought
maybe i'd go and see some cool
six guns or something and so have asked
me to sing all right i'll sing then this
thing happened and i said oh i can't do
this this is because i'm an independent
you know i'm always doing something
that's making somebody on one side or
the other
scratch their head
you know i have my conservative friend
says why have you written the ballot of
george floyd which will be on my next
record and then i have my liberal
friends why would you go play for them
you know well because i like western
guns you know that was but i didn't
think about it that way then i said no i
can't do this and i think that
i heard
again now i'm listening and hearing
things
that
there are people objecting to background
checks well that's that's again the
insanity right that i'm talking about
and there are people allowing these uh
assault rifles that's insanity
that is not for hunting or for
protecting yourself
and but if i may just digress for a
moment the idea of this second amendment
was really to have uh be able to fight
off the army back 200 years ago 200
years ago the army had a musket and a
saber and a horse and the average guy
had a musket and a saber and a horse
now there are elements in this
particular area who want to have
everything the army has
you know surface-to-air missiles you
know
bazookas so we've reached a point where
and again
you're in you're in the area of madness
and i would ban assault rifles and i
would abs absolutely insist on
background checks
so where you got to start somewhere you
know right you had a great quote donald
j i wanted to replay to you you said
there was very little left on your
bucket list i've seen everything i've
been everywhere i've done it all i love
that
well it's the truth and uh
and one thing i'll say is that uh you
know i've done things right and i've
done things wrong but i uh but it's all
down on me i don't blame anybody else
we all make mistakes in life but uh
i don't say i've done it all either i
did it if i did it right it's because i
did it right if i did it wrong it's
because i did it wrong
and um
and one thing i would say is that
um i like to know things you know and i
like to learn about things and one thing
i want to tell you is i followed your
career
and i loved your tv show when you took
over for larry king oh thank you um
i loved your tv show i still remember
many interviews that you did you were a
very very good interviewer and i always
made a point of watching it and i still
know about all the trouble you cause on
morning television with
your wonderful opinions which i most of
the time agree with completely
[Laughter]
makes me happy thank you
thank you
i just wanted to to play you a message
actually because you've become extra
famous in the uk because our champion
world heavyweight boxing hero tyson fury
loves to sing american pie when he wins
and we have a message for you from the
great man
hey tyson fury here this is a special
message to don mclean
i hear you on the pace morgan show
tonight tom
absolutely smash it brother um i loved
our rendition of american pie it was
absolutely fantastic um hi pierce
hope you're having a good time guys
don't do anything i wouldn't
and smash it good luck guys all the best
god bless you
how cool is that well you know i was i
was i was gonna tell tyson i love to
meet him someday i love him he is what
boxing has needed um he is a lovable
champion and he's a great champion and i
wanted to tell him
that um
whenever i get in trouble now i'm going
to say that i have him as my best friend
and i'm going to warn anybody who's
trying to mess with me that i have him
on speed dial you know what i mean
and and i wanted to say back to him that
if he has any trouble from like paul
simon or someone like that that i'll
handle that i can i can take paul simon
yeah final question for you don if you
could look back over your entire life
and career if i had the power to let you
relive
one moment again what would you choose
oh my word
i that's a hard question i had
so many many many wonder i've lived such
a wonderful life with people
you know
applauding me and
so much stuff that i've done
i think
i wish
that i could have
uh known my father better
right
yeah it's taken a moment
to
to know him but he was scottish and
he was 56 when he died and he was pretty
burned out anyway but
um
i i'm sorry about that i would like to
have known him better
it was an interesting time in your life
because i think you were 15 weren't you
when he died and he he never really
supported you in your dream of becoming
an entertainer
well i knew he was going to die i kept
telling everybody in the family i said
i think he's going to die and
my grandmother would say what are you
talking about i said well i can see it
they couldn't see it
and he did he right in front of me
it happened
i have this ability sometimes to
know what is going to happen before it
does
it's it's served me very well keeping me
out of trouble and
also i've always known a lot of times
what was coming around the corner not
every time but
i would have a a nagging
feeling about something and it takes
over
and it's the same
uh
antenna i think that sends the songs to
me
you know i'm really not terribly
smart or i don't read music i don't
write music but i have these visions
sometimes
i can see the song
and then i write what i see
and the words come to me because only
certain words
will do
i love the english language
that's another reason why i love the
british i love the attention to detail
and i love
the the civility for the most part and
the english language and
it's so important to me
and don what do you think your father
would have made of your incredible
success
i think he would have died again you
know i mean i think he would have just
rolled over dead i mean i don't think
you'd ever believe it you know he
thought i was destined to be uh um
lost really you've had an amazing career
uh don and i'm sad that your father
didn't get to see
what you made with it because
you know it would have been a wonderful
thing i think for him to realize that
you were right to have that dream
because the dream came true and you've
lived an amazing life and it's a real
pleasure to talk to you thank you very
much
thank you
that's it from me whatever you're up to
this weekend make sure you keep it
uncensored good night
[Music]
what was my biggest career moment after
spending about 25 years at fleet street
there's loads of stories i could tell
you but actually i think i did an
overnight show for tall radio in the
early days the night of the brexit
referendum and that was actually quite a
milestone because of course we started
off thinking um that romaine had won and
at half past two quarter three after
nigel farage had already said he lost it
turned out he hadn't lost but it turned
out we were leaving the european union
so that was quite shocking
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm zoro sullivan the high
court has ruled that next week's first
flight sending asylum seekers to rwanda
can go ahead lawyers for nearly 100
migrants had claimed the plan to send
asylum seekers to the african country
was not safe
the prime minister says ministers should
do everything in their power to secure
the release of two britons sentenced to
death for fighting against russian
forces in ukraine the families of ada
nasalin and sean pinner said they need
urgent medical and legal aid a court has
heard how an ex-soldier called 999 and
admitted to stabbing his neighbors last
year colin reeves is on trial accused of
the murder of stephen and jennifer
chapel at their home in somerset as
their children slept upstairs
well that's all for now we'll have more
after the talk
[Music]
you